turquía busca aparcar el asesinato en
octubre de 2018 del periodista saudí y
colaborador del the washington post
llaman ya show que fue asesinado cuando
entró en el consulado de su país en
estambul hace cuatro años por un equipo
de saudíes que fue enviado precisamente
a estambul para asesinar y aprender a
este periodista así lo ha explicado la
fiscalía turca a esta misma mañana
cuando ha dicho que quiere aparcar el
proceso judicial que se abrió en contra
estos presuntos autores del asesinato de
hash hoy y hace algo más de un año y que
estaban siendo juzgados in absentia en
el país anatolio esta medida se entiende
más como un una parte del proceso de
reacercamiento que es intentando llevar
a cabo turquía con los países del golfo
entre los que se encuentra a arabia
saudí turquía lo hace por varios motivos
sobre todo por intentar remontar una
economía turca muy dañada durante los
últimos meses con una lid a la moneda
local en caída libre desde hace algo más
de un par de años turquía busca así
inversiones de estos países del golfo y
el más grande de ellos es árabe saudí
para intentar remontar una economía que
pueda ayudar al presidente turco recep
tayyp erdogán a ganar las elecciones del
año bien que se prevén muy difíciles
para el presidente turco según la gran
mayoría de las encuestas
erdogán perdería su posición de
presidente en manos de la oposición y
por lo tanto erdogán extendiendo a
buscar una mejora económica que pueda
salvarle el pellejo político y su
posición a delante de turquía